In this video I want to use some of the results from
the previous few video lessons to do a few very arranged things.
Let's say this is a circle and we have a record
equilateral triangle in it.
All the tops of this triangle lie on
circle.
I will try to make an equilateral triangle.
I think that's about the best I can do.
And by saying equilateral, that means all of them
countries are of equal length.
If this is the length of the side 'a', then it is the length 'a'
and this is also a length 'a'.
Let us know that the radius of the circle is 2.
I just choose a number to make the decision.
Let's say the radius of this circle is 2.
From the center to every point
this distance, the radius, is equal to 2.
Now, what I want is to use some of the results from
the last few video lessons and a little basic
trigonometry ... if the word "trigonometry" scares you,
you only need the first two or three video lessons
in the trigonometry list so you can understand
what am I doing here?
What I want to do here is to find the faces in the figures inside
in the circle and outside the triangle.
I want to calculate this small area, that
area and these areas together.
The obvious way to do it is to say I can
to calculate the face of the circle very easily.
The face of the circle.
And this will be equal to πr ^ 2.
Or π by 2 per square, which is equal to 4π.
And I can get out of the face of the triangle.
So I have to find the face of the triangle.
What is the face of the triangle?
In several previous video lessons, I showed you the Heron formula,
where if you know the length of the sides of a triangle,
you can find the face.
But we still do not know the lengths of the parties.
Once we find them, we'll calculate the face.
Let's apply the Heron formula without knowing it.
Let's say the lengths of this equilateral triangle ...
the lengths of the sides are 'a'.
Applying the Gheron formula, we first define our variable
s to be equal to (a + a + a) / 2.
Or it is the same as 3a / 2.
And then the face of this triangle, expressed through 'a' ...
The face will be equal to the square root of s,
which is 3a / 2, in (s - a).
This is the same as 3a / 2 - a.
Or I can just write 2a / 2.
Correct? but is the same as 2a / 2.
You can shorten these and get a.
And then I'll do it three times.
And instead of just multiplying this three times for each of the parties,
according to the Genoa formula I can just say
third degree.
How will this be equal?
This will be equal to a square root of 3a / 2.
And then it will be equal here
of 3a - 2a, which is 'a'.
So a / 2 of third degree.
And this will be equal to ... arbitrarily will
changing colors.
We have 3a of a ^ 3, which is 3a ^ 4,
on 2 by 2 ^ 3.
Well, that's 2 ^ 4, or 16.
Correct?
2 by 2 ^ 3 is 2 ^ 4.
That's 16.
And if we take the square root of the numerator and the denominator,
this will be equal to the square root of
a ^ 4, which is a ^ 2.
a ^ 2 on ... will write only a square root of 3,
on a square root of the numerator, which is exactly 4.
So, if we know, using the GERON formula we find the face
of this equilateral triangle.
How can we find 'a'?
What else do we know about the equilateral triangles?
We know that all these angles are equal.
And since their sum is 180 degrees, they are
should be 60 degrees.
It's 60 degrees, it's 60 degrees
this is 60 degrees.
Now let's see if we can use the latest video where I talked about
the relationship between the entered angle
and a central angle.
This is the entry corner here.
Its tip lies on the circle.
So he cuts the rainbow here.
And the central angle that cuts the same arc
is here.
The central corner, cutting the same arc,
Based on what we saw in the last video, the central corner,
which cuts the same arc, is twice
the entered angle.
So this angle will be 120 degrees.
Let me put an arrow there.
120 degrees.
It's twice that.
Now if I lower the bisector on this corner here,
I divide that corner and I only want to
he dropped down like this.
What are these two corners?
Well, they are 60 degrees.
I divide this corner at two.
It's 60 degrees and it's 60 degrees right here.
And we know that I'm dividing this country in two.
This is an isosceles triangle.
This is a radius here.
The radius r is equal to 2.
This is a radius of r = 2.
This whole triangle is symmetrical.
If I go straight down to the middle, this length
here is this country divided into two.
This country there is this country divided into two.
Let me draw this here.
Just by taking an isosceles triangle, each isosceles triangle,
on which this country is equal to that country.
These are our radii in this example.
And this angle is equal to that angle.
If I lower the bisector on this corner here,
will split this opposite side into two.
So these two lengths will be equal.
In this case, if the whole is a, each of these
will be a / 2.
Now let's see how we can use this and a little bit of it
trigonometry to find the relationship between a and r.
Because if we can find 'a' using r, then we can
to substitute this value for 'a' here and get the face
of our triangle.
And then we can get out of his face
circle and end.
We'll solve the problem.
Let's see we can do it.
We have a 60 degree angle here.
Half of this central corner here.
If this angle is 60 degrees, we have a / 2, which is
opposed to this angle.
So we have a counterpart that is equal to a / 2.
We also have hypotenuse.
Correct?
This is a rectangular triangle here.
You go straight down and you divide
the opposite side.
It is a rectangular triangle.
We can apply a little trigonometry.
Our counterpart is a / 2, the hypotenuse equals r.
Here is the hypotenuse of our rectangular triangle.
Therefore, this is equal to 2.
What trigonometric attitude is the attitude of the opposite
the corner of the hypotenuse?
Maybe he is already tired of being constantly doing it,
but SinusCosinusTangens ...
the sine of the corner is equal to the opposite
on the hypnotheus.
Let's roll a little down.
It ends my place.
The sinus of the corner here, the sinus at 60 degrees, is
equal to the opposite side, which is
equal to a / 2, on the hypotenuse, which is
our radius divided by 2.
Which is equal to a / 2 divided by 2 is a / 4.
How much is a 60 degree sinus?
And if the word "sinus" seems completely unknown to you,
watch the first few video lessons from the section by trigonometry,
it's not too scary.
A 60 degree sinus can be remembered by
triangles with angles 30-60-90.
Let me draw one here.
This is triangle 30-60-90.
If that's 60 degrees, that's 30 degrees, that's 90 degrees.
You can remember that this is a length of 1, it is
with a length of 1/2 and a length of
square root of 3/2.
The 60-degree sinus is the opposite side to the hypotenuse.
Square root of 3/2 on 1.
Sine of 60 degrees.
If you do not have a calculator, you can just use this ...
is a square root of 3 on 2.
This here is a square root of 3 on 2.
Now we can find 'a'.
A square root of 3 on 2 is equal to a / 4.
To multiply both sides by 4.
So these 4 are shortened.
You multiply 4 here.
Here comes 2.
This is 1.
You get a = 2 per square root of 3.
We're almost at the finish.
We have just found the lengths of all sides.
We used the Gheron formula to calculate the face of
triangle at these lengths.
We simply derive this value from 'a' there,
to get our face.
The face of our triangle is equal to a ^ 2.
How much is a ^ 2?
It is 2 by square root of 3, the whole square,
by square root of 3 on 4.
We just decided a ^ 2 per square root of 3/4.
This will be equal to 4 by 3
square root of 3, on 4.
These fours are shortening.
The face of our triangle we received is
3 by square root of 3.
The face here is 3 square root of 3.
This is the face of this entire triangle.
Now to get back to the original question.
The face of this orange area outside the triangle
and within the circle.
The face of our circle is 4p.
From this we take out the face of the triangle,
3 square root of 3.
And we're done.
This is our answer.
This is the face of this orange part here.
Anyway, I hope you find it fun.